one of the engineers had to clean out
all of our equipment uh-huh
fred had a plant growing out of his out
of his booth
like a fungi do you know about this no i
do not you must eat over your board
and uh all of a sudden like a seed or
something germinated
i got pictures of it it's the most
disturbing goddamn thing you've ever
seen
dude i look at this board all the time
and it doesn't look that bad here's what
you had growing in your board
crazy they actually had a like pull it
out look at that you got a
like a plant look at it what is that i'm
shocked it looks like a bat
at any time i mean if you look at this
board now it looks pretty good you
didn't see
your well they cleaned it they cleaned
it they had to clear it all out look
look at it look at it
because usually this is out of your
board i'm not making this [ __ ] up that
is wild
that that was amazing that amazing
that's like a it's like a person
because i usually like to try and get
those like little uh clorox things that
they do i try to wipe it down and keep
it sort of clean yeah but evidently like
stuff must be good for your plant
maybe the plant likes it i'm pretty sure
you could eat what's growing out of
fred's board like
yeah i was gonna say you know like they
say you should have gardens
even if you live in the city that's
right and you imagine that something was
able to grow inside equipment
i'm wondering what that plant was
because obviously
we need that plant it's a very strong
plant
hey uh gary maybe you could take these
pictures over to a horticulturist
evan was just in here telling me he said
he cleaned your board once a year
and it's immaculate and he was surprised
at all the stuff that was in fred's
board and on the chair
yeah and i do eat the cherries the chair
is definitely disgusting but i keep my
area clean
but you're eating over there like a
maniac i eat like a maniac but i
don't know i eat over the piece of paper
and then i throw it out
i don't know what fred's doing there are
these big brown spots on fred's chair oh
the chair is disgusting i
freely admit that i've tried to wipe it
off it doesn't work
but what are you doing what happened to
it no what it is basically it's like if
i'm i'm slopping down yogurt or
something like that
and that's what it is and i try to wipe
it up with a paper towel i've actually
even tried to wipe it off with the with
the clorox [ __ ] none of it worked
is that hard to eat a yogurt i guess i
guess
for me a challenge 80 of fred's yogurt
gets in his mouth
[Laughter]
meanwhile jd's office is an enormous
mess yesterday i went in there
i'm hanging out with him and i look
under his desk and he's got boxes and
boxes and newspapers all stuffed under
his desk oh dude
that's a [ __ ] major attraction for
rats this is what i want you to do right
now
take a big giant green garbage i i i
want to go through it no no no
howard listen to me jd cause you know
what you're gonna do you're gonna go
through it you're gonna go
uh oh oh here's that dvd just do it just
do it throw it out
all right come on fred's got [ __ ]
growing in the board you got
god knows what i bet you when you throw
that out you'll find baby rats in there